what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got hit up a lot on
social media about the flash Big Game Spot
I thought it would just be shorter version
of the official trailer but apparently
there's some new footage in here now we're
gonna have to check this out go a little
bit frame by frame please check out our
reaction to the official trailer that's up
here on the channel hi koi I am excited hi
John hi I'm excited ladies and gentlemen
leave a like let's see what's going on
[Music]
cool
what's happening whoa [__] changed the future
I want some help you're you are
you're yeah I'm Batman Beyond
the supervision
dude that trailer what did they just do to us
oh he's gonna get the flash ring oh man that
was so cool wasn't the big trailer that was in
the picture I totally missed it oh yeah that's
why we're framed by Framing there you go there's a
lot happening holy crap throw a little bit Friend
by frame you guys tell me if you want me to just
stop at anything right here I mean the suit Up's
great okay so some people were saying immediately
that this was uh Christian Bale's Bat Bike uh the
Bat Bike in that movie doesn't have the the two
front wheels like this that is definitely bat
Flex that's 100 years there were set photos too
that showed that bethleck was on a a bike I think
people just want the bail so is this I can't tell
if this is a splice of like the early in the movie
or something like this is World engine from Man
of Steel moment yeah and then this I feel like
is the beginning of the movie where the whatever
that big action scene is that I imagine the film's
gonna start off with where you see that Barry
Allen is working with bat flick I don't I don't
feel like this is I don't think that's related
I agree with you yeah I think this is just some
clever match yeah and this must be like I don't
know when this is towards the end of the movie or
something like that this shot yeah I mean the Zod
Supergirl shot is so cool that is epic where is
this it looks like they're in the middle of the
desert this time yeah versus the city someplace
abandoned where they don't hey look we don't have
cases like 15 years of notes they're decided yeah
because this whole thing with the armies it looks
like it's all taking place in like a desert versus
in the middle of metropolis I mean it's like if
you have a villain that's wreaking havoc if you
take them out of the city it might be a better way
to be a hero true so some might do that what are
you talking about I don't know it's an idea and
actually slowing this down really does look like
like I don't know if this is they're both getting
Powers here or he's trying to get powers that's so
intense that's like that's so metal I love this
shot cover him jumping out of the it's very Iron
Man like yeah and Captain America Winter Soldier
where he like exactly oh that's so cool that's a
great shot we got this look at these like visuals
man I know it's in the original trailer but still
also you can see the reverse here where that
there isn't the world breaker thing and also
yeah there's also two wheels here versus with um
versus the big tumbler gas I'm like but I was just
saying for your theory of this isn't that scene
for sure because it'd be in that shot yeah well
yeah and and I thought of back to what you said
during the original trailer reaction where like
yeah it's like the Multiverse of directors because
I think people could get confused because these
bat Flex sequences on the bike do look like they
are inspired by the visual language of The Dark
Knight you know and that's you know the biggest
Touchstone on screen for that vehicle I love this
speed force moment is that a film reel yeah it
looks like it it's it's the Lost uh Snyder cut
okay who's this I have no idea who this is
gray hair long it's Berry in the future as
of his time oh Alfred he's let himself Go I
mean this looks like it's part of Wayne Manor
could be it could be but who has who has gray hair
and long gray I mean maybe we meet a different
Bruce because we're about to see a lot of Bruce's
name Keaton cuts his hair first yeah he's growing
it up first he has long hair and then he cuts it
yeah he's talking to this kid yeah I love this
shot look at this yeah and we've got a bit of a
bad armor on the on the second from the right yeah
yeah I like the different cowl attachments
and they all look in a different degree of
like wornness like that one in the back looks
especially dirty over his green left shoulder oh
yeah oh yeah I love the goggle the variations of
the device and stuff yeah and the different like
ways they for uh the like eyebrows yeah this film
looks beautiful I am so excited these shots look
very IMAX heavy yeah it gets me I'm excited for uh
for Andy muschietti too because he's the director
he's held a lot of big stuff but I'm still waiting
for like what is his stamp of you know tone and
visual you know we didn't go frame by frame with
the full trailer but they expanded on this from
the original teaser trailer yeah showing that it
is the Batmobile him freaking out the bullets to
the syncopation the music was so dope like that
was clever okay so there's your ring that's cool
what is the ring like how did he make the ring
because there's a tad bit of yellow here yeah so
it makes me think it's a 2013 berry oh interesting
I mean and is the villain just gonna be yellow
what 2012 one was Man of Steel 2012 or 2013 2012.
yeah but also are we getting uh you know yellow
flash I don't think that's this shot but like is
the evil Flash gonna be a part of this or is it
gonna be like yeah in the universe where he still
has his mom he doesn't have powers then flash
gives him his powers but then that causes him to
turn into yellow flash that's a good point too can
we can we acknowledge that he kind of has a blue
Cape here with gray yes this is a bit Neil Adams
and that is my jam I love me a blue suit this is
definitely the continuation of him coming out of
the plane oh that is so freaking cool that's gonna
be a great secret it's gonna be so giving him like
a good final sequence yeah I don't know what
he's freaking out over here he's just uh he's
responding to the charger it might be when his
mom is getting murdered trying to be watching the
old murder yeah uh okay there's a lot of dude like
this is all army with these these lightning bolts
which is interesting well this looks like it's the
two flashes yeah no no I was just looking at what
they're attacking like I'm wondering if this is
like they're losing the fight and everything comes
down to them kind of thing uh well that's the
two of them in the middle and then they're just
gonna like shoot off to one side I think either
trying to save the people oh they're trying to
save the soldiers these are yeah like are these
kryptonians are these ours I thought only show
up with a small handful of people but he's got
like ships and yeah these are these look alien
these ships yeah the ships I'm saying they're
fighting with them yeah but these look like
they're regular I can't see that's what I can't
tell yeah I thought troops or if those are Zod
troops or it could be them fighting yeah either
way it's interesting I like the Starship Trooper
my favorite shot is now this blue and gray
suit like I'm just overwhelmed by Ben Affleck
and blue and right that's so exciting that's
a cool TV spot I'm excited for this movie man
I think it's gonna be cool it's gonna be
red it's James Gunn's favorite movie all
right guys well you excited for the flash of
your thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
totally missed the ring in the last video I
just I'm so impressed that it looks as good
as we've heard because it we heard the sky
was gonna Park yep all right guys so leave
your thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
follow koi on the socials last but not least
Aaron Myers Buddy Aaron my dude we have a
bunch of shout out ideas for you but you
know what we're gonna do we're gonna start for
the traditional one we looked up in the meaning
of your name it means exalted or strong it's
been interpreted to mean teacher or mountain
of strength that is so cool I like to imagine
that you are a skinny scrawny little guy with
like four different sets of glasses and you're
constantly having your head down and you have
a hoodie yard gear shaggy hair a bunch of
inhalers you're always using the last thing
you want is any sort of conflict and someone
shoves you into the locker room and you're
always covered in a body cast my name's Aaron
I have a mountain I am fragile do not break me
um yeah you know he did a completely opposite
thing of what what I said there but we were on
the same page for so long you know yeah I'm
sorry Aaron I was just intimidated by your
strength as the mountain of strength that you
are just kidding we know that you're probably
a very very handsome individual with um
and you I'm sure you put on this display
here every Aaron I've ever got to know is a
great guy and exclusively I think they are
an exalted individual that's what I always say
that's that's a common compliment that I give
around town you are exalted sir you're an exotic
person you are exalted this Eve so and you are
especially exalted thank you Aaron for being here
for being part of our patreon page for bumping up
here obviously we don't really know what you
look like so I'd please don't take anything
but uh thank you for thank you for
showing your support man it means
a lot to have you as a super sexy
reject here at the reject Nation